the falcon and the winter soldier is
full of everything that makes the mcu
special
action super powers witty jokes and of
course a ton of easter eggs for the
attentive fan
here are a few you might have missed in
episode 2 the star-spangled man
just before bucky barnes and sam attempt
to jump the flag smashers the two have
one of many hilarious exchanges in an
abandoned warehouse
bucky's stealthy behavior prompts sam to
call him the white panther as a joke
referencing the time bucky spent in
wakanda after the events of captain
america civil war
bucky quickly corrects him it's actually
why wolf
this confuses sam for a moment but the
scene moves on without further
discussion we first see bucky referred
to as the white wolf in the second
post-credits scene from black panther
some village children refer to bucky by
this name while he's residing in wakanda
under the watch of shuri
t'challa later calls bucky this name
during avengers infinity war before
giving him a new vibranium arm for the
impending battle against thanos army
the falcon of the winter soldier marks
the first time we've heard bucky revert
to himself as the white wolf
in the comics the winter soldier and the
white wolf aren't the same character
instead the white wolf is hunter
t'challa's adopted white brother
king t'chaka takes hunter in as an
infant after he crash lands in wakanda
with his parents who don't make it out
of the wreckage alive
he eventually becomes the leader of the
wakandan secret police and takes on the
white wolf moniker
while john walker the new captain
america is practicing for his first big
interview he's greeted by a friend who
gives him a pep talk
later this man officially introduces
himself as lamar hoskins to sam and
bucky after the tractor-trailer highway
battle and even reveals his hero name
battle star first appearing in 1986 is
captain america number 323
hoskins was a wrestler until he was
granted superhuman abilities by the
power broker his bond with john walker
is strong
the two are picked by the government to
be the new cap and bucky this explains
why our bucky gets angry at the mention
of battlestar and hops out of the car
when he and sam talk to the pair after
the highway battle
in the comics hoskins is part of a group
called the bold urban commandos
aka the buckies the buckies and walker
are known at this time as super patriot
battle steve rogers and lose some time
after this the government taps walker to
become the new captain america and
hoskins as the new bucky the latter
eventually dubs himself battlestar
in 1989's captain america number 350
steve regains the mantle of captain
america prompting battlestar to retire
to his hometown of chicago
as an angry sam and bucky walk away from
their highway battle defeats in the
star-spangled man
walker and hoskins ride up on them bucky
tells walker that holding the shield
doesn't mean he's captain america and
asks if walker has ever jumped on top of
a grenade
yeah actually i have four times the
thing i do with my helmet it's a
reinforced
helmet it's a long story it's not
exactly the same thing that our friend
steve rogers does in captain america the
first avenger
while training in boot camp colonel
chester phillips tosses a dead grenade
at a group of his recruits to see how
they respond
without hesitation rogers still weak and
skinny at this point dives on top of the
grenade to absorb the explosion and
protect those around him
it's one of the character's most
memorable and moving heroic deeds
and bucky's subtle invocation of it
speaks volumes
we meet isaiah bradley and the
star-spangled man after bucky and sam
fail in their fight against the flag
smashers
in a brief conversation we learned that
bucky and isaiah have battled one
another in the past and that the latter
was actually able to rip off half of
bucky's arm
first appearing in 2003's truth red
white and black number one
isaiah is sometimes known as the black
captain america
he and 299 other black soldiers are
experimented on as part of governmental
efforts to replicate the super soldier
serum
though isaiah shows enormous bravery
during world war ii is court-martialed
and imprisoned for 17 brutal years
in the falcon and the winter soldier
isaiah reveals he was in jail for 30
years during which constant tests were
performed upon him
bucky let sam know that isaiah is a hero
and is feared by hydra as steve rogers
was
one of the ones that hydra fear the most
like steve
founded by curtis jackson power broker
is both an organization and a man first
appearing in 1978's machine man number
seven
jackson aims to profit from making super
soldiers despite the extreme riskiness
of the process in the comics the power
broker transforms both john walker and
lamar hoskins into super soldiers
their superhuman strength is hinted at
during the highway battle seen in the
star-spangled man
when bucky mentions that the flag
smashers are super soldiers hoskins acts
surprised by the term
as though he doesn't know such people
exist beyond steve rogers and bucky
this could be an effort to throw bucky
off descent if hoskins is in fact
already a super soldier himself
it's suspected that the power broker is
responsible for the flag smasher's
superhuman abilities
but one of their members mentions the
power brokers man are the ones coming
after them during the private plane
escape scene
we don't yet know why they're being
chased by the power broker but it could
be an effort to de-augment them
jackson's a dr carl malus experiments
with that process on battlestar
in the comics luckily walker saves his
pal in the nick of time
as always if you want to impress your
friends with your marvel easter egg
knowledge you need to pay close
attention to any numbers that appear on
screen
at the end of the star spangled man
there's a quick shot of zemo in prison
with the footage noting that his cell
number is 2187
no need to hunt your back issues though
since this isn't actually a reference to
zemo's comic book origins
instead it's a reference to a different
story from a long time ago in a galaxy
far
far away in star wars a new hope
princess leia's cell number is 2187
a number that reappears in the force
awakens where it's used as finn's
stormtrooper designation
both appearances of the number are
actually a reference to 2187 a national
film board of canada's short that
inspired a young george lucas
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite comic book heroes and
villains are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]